es una cuestión que se repiten las altas
esferas políticas de Europa llegarán los
tanques el leopard de Polonia Ucrania
este lunes el gobierno polaco confirmó
que piensa mandarlos y que buscará otra
vía para hacerlo si no recibe la
aprobación de Berlín
solicitaremos dicho consentimiento pero
este es un tema secundario Incluso si al
final no obtenemos ese consentimiento
como parte de una pequeña coalición
Incluso si los alemanes no están en esa
coalición aún así entregaremos nuestros
tanques junto con otros países a Ucrania
y es que Alemania como fabricante debe
otorgar el permiso de reexportación
hacia Ucrania a los países que poseen
estos tanques pero de momento el
gobierno alemán parece no tener una
postura común mientras el cancillero
labshol se muestra escéptico por una
posible escalada la ministra de
exteriores aseguró que no hay motivo
para negar la operación
Por el momento no se ha planteado la
cuestión pero si nos la plantearan no
nos interpondríamos
desde la Unión Europea algunos países
como lituania aseguraron que no hay
buenos argumentos para negar el envío
algo que no ven igual desde el kremlin
que señaló a todos los países que
suministren armas a Ucrania como
responsables de la guerra
Pero por supuesto todos los países que
están involucrados directa o
indirectamente en el suministro de armas
a Ucrania y en el aumento de sus
capacidades tecnológicas son
responsables de esto
Lo principal es que es el pueblo
ucraniano quien pagará el precio de todo
este falso apoyo
Ucrania lleva meses pidiendo los tanques
el leopard ya que el conflicto sin
grandes avances ha pasado a ser una
guerra de desgaste y los tanques
ayudarían a Ucrania a avanzar posiciones
los expertos creen que ambos bandos
están planeando ofensivas para la
próxima Primavera